hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in today's video
i want to address a very big scam
that has recently happened and i'm going
to talk you through the details i have
written an article about this
if you want to get the full details
check it out in the article below the
government have published a statement on
this as well
so basically here's what happened this
is the scary thing so there was a guy
called
mitchell malin and what he did was he
told investors
that he wanted to borrow money and he
would
use that money to invest in property
and then he would give them uh fixed
returns and and shares and whatnot
that's what he did
and his company was shut down in 2018
and in 2021 he has just been banned
from being the director of a company for
14
years because here is what he did so he
took money off people in fact
he took as much as 13 million
13 million and with all of the money
he only bought one house
with the money so it's a pretty shocking
story people were investing from five
000 pounds right up to 100 000 pounds
taking the money no security no
guarantees
and then he was basically squandering
the money acting illegally
and that the government have just
published an article about it on the
government website
so not good very very bad what's the
lesson from this the lesson is really
important and that is
to get educated get educated
have your mind open to opportunities
but don't have it so open
that you've got no education that your
brain falls out you know
and if you're investing a hundred grand
into someone's deal
because you don't know what you're doing
why not just put one percent
one percent of that hundred grand into
your education first
pay a consultant pay a mentor to look
over the deals
pay a lawyer i consider my lawyers
as mentors so you know that's a real
shame that happens there have been quite
a lot of
scams going around even in my youtube
comments i see people pretending to be
me
and asking people for money so the key
key key is to get educated and also
here's another thing that you can do you
can think
i don't want to get scammed i don't want
to get scammed so you can keep holding
your money and put it in the bank and
then what guess what
that's kind of a scam as well because
the bank
will then invest it strategically
because they're educated
and then your money is shrinking and
depreciating so
the key in all of this is to
learn how to invest do it properly do it
yourself
and i think right now one of the best
ways to invest in property
is to invest in hmos buy a property
and rent it out room by room and i would
love
to educate and share how to do that in
the right way
so that it's safe also in a strategic
way
so that you can buy properties for
example in areas
where article 4 is coming in so that you
can then get the
planning gain on the property so there's
a whole bunch of stuff i'd love to share
with you around investing smart in
properties of multiple occupancy
um and i am offering a free
webinar on give back friday friday's a
giveaway friday
so if you'd like to join me on the
webinar it's coming soon i've got a link
below
with all of the details it's completely
free there is no catch
so get registered at the hmo 101 webinar
it's virtual it's free you can do it
from your home
and i think you're going to absolutely
love it if you enjoy my channel where i
every single day put out a video
educating giving tips
then please please please do subscribe
smash the like button get registered
and i'll see you on the webinar if not
at the live
in person crash course so have a
wonderful weekend and i will see you
soon
i'm gonna be running a one day advanced
training program it's gonna be a full
day
an intensive day and i'm gonna be
teaching everything i know about
property
listen i started in poverty when i was
17 years old bought my first house age
17 with no mana
i'm gonna be showing exactly how i did
that and how you can do the same thing
i then built up a large portfolio
multi-million pound box portfolio much
profit did you make the first week
that's not bad in a week uh i earn like
four thousand pound a month and i do not
do 40 hours a week
it's almost almost ten thousand just if
you thrown around it's like 10.
three four beds and a six bed so from
the 21st
right up until about i think the 29th
i'm gonna be touring
running my training and the tickets
are now available on the website the
tickets are
free